pour le seul mois d'octobre notre pays a
détruit 4 millions de doses de vaccins
moderna utilisés contre la covid 19
cette gabgie faite en toute discrétion
représente un montant de près de 80
millions d'euros comme le révèle
aujourd'hui le journal l'Humanité en mai
dernier ce sont plus de 3 millions de
vaccins à straseneca qui ont subi le
même sort il est très probable que
d'autres ont également été jetés à la
poubelle dans les mois précédents et que
les mois à venir verront ce scénario se
répéter au-delà de la nécessité d'avoir
la garantie d'instock suffisante de
vaccins de la question des dates de
péremption et du fait que ces vaccins
première génération ne soient pas très
adapté aux nouveaux variants nous sommes
face à un véritable scandale sanitaire
et financier dès l'arrivée des premiers
vaccins nous avons dénoncé la caparment
par les pays riches des stocks de
vaccins au détriment des pays pauvres
nous sommes en train de détruire des
doses faute de les avoir utilisé quand
dedans quand de nombreux pays n'y ont
pas eu accès dès le début nous avons de
dénoncer le manque de transparence dans
les négociations avec les laboratoires
et l'opacité des contrats sur les
volumes le calendrier de livraison les
prix au nom du secret des affaires je
vous invite à lire combien coûte nos
vies en quête sur les politiques du
médicament de Pauline londex et Jérôme
Martin co-fondateur de l'Observatoire de
la transparence dans les politiques du
médicament vous avez refusé de lever les
brevets et par votre politique vous avez
permis à l'industrie pharmaceutique de
faire des profits des super profits pour
reprendre une expression très en vogue
le tout sur le dos de la pandémie 26
milliards pour Pfizer en 2022 12
milliards pour moderna on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui alors monsieur le
ministre je vais vous faire un cadeau je
vais vous donner en main propre le
rapport que j'ai fait sur la création
d'un pôle public du médicament ainsi que
la proposition de loi que nous avons
faite au niveau du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen il y a beaucoup
d'informations extrêmement intéressantes
[Musique]